thanks jc if you're considering some
subtle and inconspicuous face work it's
time to call chicla v at smith plastic
surgery for a
non-surgical facelift here's dr john
manoli to explain
non-surgical face lifting essentially is
not doing a standard face neck lift
essentially what that means is the
standard incisions that are placed
around the ear
into the temporal hair into the behind
the ear hair are not made or only
slightly made
in combination with other non-surgical
techniques to
produce a result that starts to
approximate
what a face neck lift is these days
especially in the last few years
thread lifting barbed thread lifting of
dissolvable
monofilament threads has led the way as
one of the elements that helps patients
achieve
really a great sense of restoration and
rejuvenation and refreshment of their
face
without the downtime that's associated
with
the longer more detailed standard
face neck lift surgery i performed both
and i i saw
uh in the last few years that people
were crying out for a bridge they didn't
want the surgery but they wanted
something
what do we mean by threads thread is
used in sewing
sutures can be considered threads but
really the thread lifting as we know it
today is a semantic
term that's used in in society that
people can
trigger on a thread is a barb stitch and
the thread lifting that we're talking
about now
are dissolvable barb stitches it's
actually fairly routinely done the
thread lifting
is an adjunct to the fillers and the
neuromodulators
we're so familiar with today the botox
the juvederm the restylane those are
filler categories
now we add threads as an adjunct and
we're having two things work at once
although actually i i stagger the
treatments i usually have
my thread lifting first to establish a
nice support of the face
and then weeks later i can come back and
more subtly fill in with the injectables
thereby preventing that kind of overdone
hyperbolic cartoonish look that you see
all over
[Music]
all over the big cities fish lips duck
whips
that's what we're trying to avoid the
obvious statement that i have
been to my plastic surgery let's talk
about the benefits
we've been referring to them already
there is actually the improvement
of the tightening of and the lifting of
soft tissues
all over the body i happen to stress the
face and the neck but it
is used in the lower extremities in the
upper extremities
but i'm finding that it's more
adjunctive with traditional
fillers and in combination the two or
three
treatments together
amalgamated produce a more natural
result
classic guy right there call chic la vie
at 702 702-838-2455